Macari mommy actually as mila chaser it
means what's up lady can I buy you a
drink
milky snack pack attack as a Jew I
should be able to read this package but
I also dropped out of Hebrew school
looks like cottage cheese maybe okay
probably not and this one's like hot
chocolate it's just chocolate pudding
with whipped cream on top
basically delicious treat oh so good oh
my god all right Israelis it's in pop
rocks in chocolate this looks like it
could be dangerous
ain't no fire Oh what it crackles in
your mouth oh my god it's like when
you're at like a club and you think the
party's over but it's not because it's
still going in my mouth right now I can
hear you always Fred and George Weasley
would totally think something like this
bamba' peanut snack I think that's what
I'm gonna start calling I don't know
where am i working bomba fandom means
baby basketball
they look like Cheetos but they smell
like peanuts there's an interest in I do
not like it it's like putting a cheeto
in your mouth and then it turns into
peanut butter I hate them but I want
more of them they're flavored wheat
snacks it's like not an attractive
slogan dude I think we could dress up
like these guys who are these two cool
cats I need an earring and a little bit
of chin hair I think I got it that
smells like falafel oh my god it does
the shape is not appealing it's honestly
like some sort of rodent food I'm really
into these yeah it's like a good bar
snack you could break these down and use
them as breading for fried chicken you
could put this on your green bean
casserole you can put it on your salad
you could put it on your pitas ice cream
sandwiches live it up
boom Oh like a Goomba yeah I feel like
it looks a lot like a Diglett you know
it looks like a malamar but that looks
like a lot of fun inside my question is
what is this the marshmallow is actually
a lot like marshmallow fluff then the
cookie at the bottom delicious is just a
little cumbersome whoever invented this
snack is just like a master of the craft
Ezek mom it's a milk chocolate bar
filled with flavor and hazelnuts cream
hmm sounds like Nutella
yeah it looks super gooey and amazing on
the thing and then it just sort of looks
like fuzzy this is like the successful
globe-trotting older brother of a
kick-ass break me off a piece of that
pets come on that's good we approve
Israel good job I wonder if it's really
hard to find bacon and Israel yes of
course it is do you think that like
there's kosher places here that just
sell kosher food there's only places in
Israel that's all like bacon and
lobsters and that's it